in the last episode we looked at how to
store our unstructured data
in this episode we'll learn how to run
custom training jobs on vertex ai i'm
nikita and this is prototype to
production where we go from notebook
code to a deployed model in the cloud
[Music]
you might be wondering why do i need a
training service when i can just run
model training directly in my notebook
well for models that take a long time to
train a notebook isn't always the most
convenient option and if you're building
an application with ml it's unlikely
you'll only need to train your model
once
over time you'll want to retrain your
model to make sure it stays fresh and
keeps producing valuable results
manually executing the cells of your
notebook might be the right option when
you're getting started with a new ml
problem but when you want to automate
experimentation at scale or retrain
models for a production application a
managed ml training option will make
things much easier not to mention vertex
ci training comes with additional
features like hyper parameter tuning
distributed training support and
integration with other parts of vertex
ai
running a custom training job on vertex
ai is done with containers
don't panic if you don't know a whole
lot about containers or docker i'm going
to show you exactly what you need to
know
containers are packages of your
application code which in this case is
our training code
together with dependencies like specific
versions of libraries required to run
your code in addition to helping with
dependency management containers are
able to run virtually anywhere allowing
for increased portability
docker is the tool we'll use to create
these containers vertex ai training
provides a set of pre-built containers
if one of these containers meets your
needs in other words has all the
libraries needed for your use case you
can provide your training code as a
python source distribution and vertex ai
will manage the container for you
but if your training application
requires libraries that are not included
in these images or it contains code
that's not written in python or maybe
you just want better control over the
dependencies you'll want to use a custom
image and that's what i'll show you next
now our flowers model only requires
tensorflow so we can actually just use
the pre-built tensorflow image
but when it's time for you to run your
own experiments you might find yourself
with the use case that's a little more
complicated
plus knowing some basics of how to
containerize code with docker is a great
skill for anyone doing machine learning
here's a quick summary of the steps that
we'll take to run our training job
first we'll export our notebook to a
python file
then we'll update our code so that we
read the data in from cloud storage and
save the model out to cloud storage
next we'll containerize our code with
docker and lastly we'll launch a custom
training job our code is all in this
notebook right here in workbench but we
want to work with the python file
instead
we can do this conversion with the nb
convert tool from the terminal
we execute the command jupyter nbconvert
then the name of our notebook dash dash
to python and we see that we now have a
file called task.pi which is the python
file equivalent of our notebook
recall that in the previous episode we
uploaded the flowers dataset to a bucket
called prototype to production bucket
in our training code we want to read in
data directly from that bucket
using the cloud storage fuse tool
training jobs on vertex ai can access
data on cloud storage as files in the
local file system
when you start a custom training job the
job sees a directory backslash gcs which
stands for google cloud storage
that contains all of your cloud storage
buckets as subdirectories
not only does this make it easy to
access your data but it also provides
high throughput for large file
sequential reads so to access the images
in our bucket all we need to do on our
code is set the path of our data
directory to be slash gcs slash the name
of our bucket
flower photos
but we don't just want to read data from
cloud storage we also want to make sure
our trained model is saved to cloud
storage that way we can access it later
for deployment and predictions
you might be used to calling model.save
and passing in a local path
when we launch this training job it's
going to run on a machine we won't have
access to after the job completes
so we don't want model.save to be a
local path instead we want it to be a
path in cloud storage
so let's update our model.save path to
the name of our bucket slash model
output which will update our save model
artifacts to the same bucket in a
different directory
okay our training code is ready so it's
time to containerize it let's return to
the terminal and structure our
application
first i'll create a directory called
flowers and within that a directory
called trainer
trainer is where all of our training
code will go so i'll move the task.pi
file there then from the root of the
flower directory we'll create our docker
file let's review what we just did our
application looks something like this
remember all of our training code is in
the trainer directory in the task.pi
file
in this example we only have one python
file in our trainer directory but for a
more realistic example you would likely
have additional files
maybe you've got one called data.pi
which handles data preprocessing and one
called model.pi which just has the model
code etc in our docker file we'll write
a series of commands which is what the
vertex ai training service will execute
let's take a deeper look at the syntax
the from command specifies the base
container image which is the parent
container that the container we create
will be built on top of
as our base container image we'll use
the tensorflow enterprise gpu docker
image since it comes with all of the
packages we need
the workdir command specifies the
directory in the container where
subsequent instructions are run
the copy command copies the trainer code
to the docker container image and if you
wanted to add any additional libraries
you could use the run command to pip
install but we don't need anything
additional for our example here
lastly the entry point command sets up
the entry point to invoke the trainer
this is what we'll run when we start our
training job in our case that's
executing the task.pi file and that's it
with this formula you know enough to
start writing dockerfiles for your
training code now that the dockerfile
has been written we need to build our
container and push it to artifact
registry which is a place for storing
container images in google cloud
we'll start by defining the path and
artifact registry where we want to store
the container image
then we can call docker build
and when our image is built we'll push
it to artifact registry
if you missed any of these commands
don't worry i've written them all out in
the codelab linked below
once the image is pushed we'll be able
to see it in the console under artifact
registry
again this container image has all of
our training code and the dependencies
that we need
so now we're ready to launch our
training job
under the training section of the
console select create
select custom training advanced as your
training method
give your model a name
in the container settings select custom
container and then we'll add the path to
our container in artifact registry
we specify our compute
and we'll skip the prediction container
step for now and do that in the next
episode
finally we click start training
if you'd like to learn how to launch
training jobs using the python sdk
instead of the ui check out the code lab
linked below
under the custom jobs tab we can track
the status of our training job we can
click on the name to see the details on
the configuration
and when it's finished we can see the
logs
we'll also see the saved model artifacts
here in our cloud storage bucket
in this episode we talked about the
benefits of a managed training service
and walk through the steps required to
train custom models on vertex ai in the
next episode we'll use this model to get
low latency predictions with the vertex
ai prediction service be sure to check
out the code lab linked below which
provides detailed instructions on
everything we covered today
and don't forget to like and subscribe
for more great content and i'll see you
next time